Kevin Hart is on the men following a car
accident early Sunday morning you one
life you get one life the comedians wife
and eco shared an update to paparazzi on
his condition as she went to visit him
at the hospital Monday quote he's going
to be just fine she added the comedian
is awake but not laughing or joking just
yet et has confirmed that Hart was in
the passenger seat at the time of the
crash in Calabasas California at 12:45
a.m. Sunday morning a California Highway
Patrol press release States Hart's 1970
Plymouth Barracuda quote left the road
and rolled over and down the northern
embankment he was taken to a nearby
hospital as a result of major back
injuries et has learned that Hart is
resting comfortably after he had back
surgery but remains hospitalized the
comedian is getting plenty of love from
fellow celebs during this time his
frequent co-star Dwayne Johnson posted a
photo of the duo and the upcoming
Jumanji sequel caption quote stop
messing with my emotions brother Kevin
Hart for real we have a lot more
laughing to do together love you man
stay strong Jamie Foxx also took to
Instagram to send positive vibes and
prayers Salma Hayek posted a sweet
black-and-white image and Mindy Kaling
sent her well wishes on Twitter and
everybody watching guys what I love you
you know what else I love making the
world laugh
you